savez-vous quel est le rôle du Conseil
de quartier ou encore ce qui a une
position latérale de sécurité près de
200 jeunes inimontains âgés de 10 à 13
ans S sont essayés lors de la 11e
édition nationale du City r secours
d'éducation civique grandeur nature à
travers la ville première étape chez les
pompiers ditesmi les questionsy v
réponses quel est le numéro de téléphone
des pompiers al c'est lequel 11 le
118 la pu je Tromp très bien à chaque
point de passage les équipes doivent
répondre à un questionnaire sur
l'histoire inimontaine et le rôle des
institutions agréablement surpris sur
les sur les questions qui peuvent poser
teles que donc les premiers secours où
il y en a déjà il y a déjà des des
jeunes qui qui connaissent la position
latérale de sécurité les détecteurs de
fumée très important à partir de 2015
dans chaque domicile obligatoire et donc
toutes ces questions sont assez
intéressantes pour la jeune génération
qui arrive les enfants découvrent les
gestes de premier secours peuvent se
mettre dans la peau des soldats du feu
le temps de quelques instants sur le
parcours sportif et surtout avec la
lance incendie ça donne envie justement
faire pompier plus tard aller dans
l'armée ou pas ou pant ce temp tu as
d'autreses idées ouais j'avais voulais
être ingénieur mais là je sais pas trop
retour à la mairie de Montini pour les
derniers ateliers initiation au vote
découverte des véhicules qui
transportent les militaires français au
Mali et quelques épreuves sportive pour
se défouler avant le classement général
les quatre meilleures équipes se
rendront à la finale nationale
le juin à Paris